hello I'm Richard Anderson I am the P I
on NIH brain initiative and NIH funded
research on advancing human neuroscience
through the development of neural
prosthetics today members of our team
will be discussing how multidisciplinary
research can advance clinical and basic
research of the human nervous system the
title of our panel is thought to action
developing brain machine interfaces to
assist individuals with paralysis so a
brain machine interface essentially
consists of three components there is a
recording electrode array a decoder and
an assistive device so the recordings
are made of neural signals those signals
are decoded to determine the intent of
the individual and then those are formed
into a control signal to control
assistive devices such as robotic limbs
or computers the implant that we use is
a tiny array of a hundred electrodes it
records 100 to 150 neurons and then the
decoder uses the information from those
neurons to determine the intent of the
individual now the types of paralysis
that can benefit from brain machine
interfaces are patients with spinal cord
injuries stroke multiple sclerosis and
Liat rope
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis and
Deschenes
muscular dystrophy participants in our
study have tetraplegia from high level
spinal cord injury so the incidence of
this is quite high around 250 to 350,000
people in the u.s. currently have spinal
cord injury about half are at the high
cervical level our participants are all
at the high-level injury
a cervical level see three through six
and they are tetraplegic meaning that
they all four limbs are paralyzed and
they've also lost feeling in those four
limbs there are very few assistive
technologies for them and they have very
high dependence on caregivers this
research is by definition
multidisciplinary and it first of all
includes our participants they work very
hard they're very dedicated without them
this research wouldn't be possible and
they do this selflessly not to benefit
themselves but for those that will
follow as the technology develops we
also have at Caltech a Chen brain
machine interface Center that includes
our laboratory and we collaborate as
well with the Shapiro laboratory and
mommy laboratories here at Caltech on
technical advances also for technology
we work with the tantor lab in Paris we
of course must work with the clinician
we worked with neurosurgeons at Keck USC
hospital and at the UCLA Medical Center
it is very important to have restoration
hospitals involved for us it's Rancho
Los Amigos and Casa Colina both rehab
centers in the Los Angeles area and then
finally we also collaborate with other
universities and hospitals on scientific
projects today we'll have four key
investigators from our group speaking
there's myself and I trained in
neurophysiology Spencer Kahless who's
Caltech and USC trained in engineering
Tyson a swallow trained in neural
computation here at Caltech
and our clinical colleague Charles Luke
who's a neurosurgeon at USC initially we
began our work and non-human primates
understanding visual motor integration
in the cortex and we found that vision
projects vision cortical areas project
into the posterior parietal cortex where
intentions to move or form and that
projects then to motor cortex and we
found an area that was specialized for
reach another force of cards
socata and colleagues found an area that
specialized for grass and from this we
proposed that there was a map of
intentions within the monkey cortex and
that possibly something similar would be
found in human and we could record the
intention of humans in a prosthetic
application and use it to help paralyzed
people now this next slide shows the
basic problem of breaking the loop
between vision and motor output with
spinal cord lesion so you can see an
object and process it through visual
cortex posterior parietal cortex for
intensive motor cortex to send a command
signal down to the spinal cord for
making a movement however if the spinal
cord is severed then the muscles can't
be activated so groups have recorded
from motor cortex to get the execution
signal for prosthetic applications this
makes a lot of sense because the motor
cortex is the final motor output from
the cortex to the spinal cord we've
since we've had oh and by the way from
motor cortex you can get the trajectory
of the limb movement which is the limb
one limb on the contralateral side from
our experiments in posterior parietal
cortex looking at intention in animals
we found that not only could we get
trajectories but also the goals of
movement and
can be very fast we also found that the
cells code for movements of both limbs
and that there were neurons specialized
for different grass shapes so a single
neuron can convey an entire grass so six
years ago we implanted our first subject
Eric's or toe and we in our studies we
asked the subjects what they would like
to do as a goal within the study and in
Eric's case he wanted to be able to
drink a beer at his own rate in other
words not have someone do it for him and
so in the video that you'll be seeing
this is the first time he was able to
drink a beer at his own rate in this
case he was controlling the timing of
the sequence of the robotic movement
with his brain signals since then he has
been able to use and brain signals to
identify the goals of a movement and the
action that he wants to perform on those
objects so if you could please now run
the video
[Music]
pick up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we found that the variables that we
thought we would find from the monkey
research was there in humans as well so
we could decode goals and trajectories
and also grasp shapes however we found
many many more variables as well we
could decode the movement of individual
fingers we could essentially decode the
intended movement of all of the body and
he parted the body and we also found we
could decode action observation and
action semantics so a question became
how is this possible how can recording
from so few neurons in such a small
patch of cortex enable us to decode so
much and the answer we found in
experiments that were designed to see
how information was encoded in the
posterior parietal cortex so this is one
example for action semantics in this
case we showed the subject videos from
three different points of view of
subjects performing actions on objects
and also showed them in a fourth format
a word a verb for the action in this
case graph and we did this for five
different kinds of actions to operate on
objects to drag them drop them grasp
push or rotate and this one neuron as
you see on the left was active for
rotating an object from any perspective
and also by silently reading the word
rotate so this would be in a neuron
invariant to the
particular action the type and here's a
cell that's similar but not with the
language component here's one that has
rather a mix and additional one with the
mix of various actions and here's one
that is active only when reading the
word grass so what this shows is that
for in this case this particular class
of experiments action semantics there's
a mix selectivity in the population of
neurons for the action type this is
another experiment examining this mixing
here we're looking at mixed selectivity
for the left and right hand for two
different actions and speech so it's
attempted movement of the hand imagine
movement of the hand or to speak left or
right and here is a neuron that is
active for attempt and imagine the right
hand moving this next one is for attempt
just of the left hand the third neuron
is active only for imagining left or
right hand movements and this final
their own is active when the subject
says left but not right and otherwise is
not active and this is a similar
experiment except here we've replaced
speech with shoulder movements and again
we're looking at strategy of imagined
versus attempt and inside of the body
left and right and effectors are doubt
the shoulder and the hand and one
possible way of mixing is shown in the
upper part of the panel in which
everything is randomly mixed and we
found that this is not the case actually
there's a structure to the mixing so
there are different sub spaces for the
effectors one for shoulder and one for
hand and within those sub spaces are
overlapping strategy and side of the
body representations so one advantage of
the
representations for the side and
strategy is that you there's an overlap
in learning so it's been shown that you
can learn something with the right hand
it more easily transfers to left hand or
you can use imagery to improve motor
performance and advantage as the
segregation and representation of the
shoulder in the hand is that shoulder
movements are very different from hand
movements in this thus there's little
advantage and potential interference
from having them overlapping now for the
semantic encoding of action type we'd
likewise found this structure so the
segregation was a long action type for
instance the grasp verb and grass videos
are partially segregated from those from
the other actions such as rotate so this
is basically the answer to how so many
things can be represented in such a
small number of neurons
it says partially mixed selectivity that
is it enables all these variables to be
encoded across the population of cells
and can be extracted with the decoder
current extensions of our research are
in cortical micro stimulation to restore
the somatic sensation that's lost
Spencer Kahless will talk about this and
the question here is an artificial
sensation be natural and improved extra
control of a robot hand the talk by - a
swallow will it be a direct comparison
between the posterior parietal cortex
and motor cortex and one question that
he'll be addressing is whether it's
important to pick the right cortical
area based on the intended applications
or will plasticity allow any cortical
area to suffice we'll also be looking in
the future on whether the posterior
parietal cortex is indeed higher
dimensional than motor cortex
other studies that we're doing but we
won't talk about in this panel are using
functional ultrasound this is with
mikhail shapiro and mikhail catcher labs
and the aim of those studies is to
develop minimally invasive brain machine
interfaces for use in humans also we are
looking at machine learning decoding
with azita Mommy's group but here at
Caltech they are seeing if they can
design decoders on microchips that can
be implanted in the brain and learn to
decode neural signals thank you very
much hi my name is Spencer Kellis I'm a
member of the professional staff at
Caltech and a research assistant
professor of Neurosurgery at the Keck
School of Medicine at USC and one of the
benefits of working in both institutions
is the opportunity to work closely with
a multidisciplinary team of physician
scientists and engineers in this talk
I'll be discussing how we're able to
leverage these opportunities to work and
to understand generating somatosensory
Kristoff's
with a broader set of patients and a
broader set of electro types at Caltech
I'm involved in a clinical trial of
brain machine interfaces in that trial
we have one tetraplegic participant FG
who has micro electrode arrays implanted
and ventral premotor cortex or PMD super
marginal gyrus or SMG and the
somatosensory cortex as highlighted in
red and there's image on the right these
micro electrode arrays are manufactured
by Blackrock Microsystems they're very
small devices as you can see and the
lower right they're about four
millimeters on a side which means that a
hundred electrodes fit in to the sides
fit into an area smaller than the size
of a penny and that means when we're
stimulating queues you through these
electrodes we're targeting a very small
area of cortex and we use very small
amplitude electric current for the
stimulation a USC
we work with epilepsy patients who are
undergoing surgical treatment for their
epileptic condition now these patients
have a different kind of electrode
implanted these are called electric
coreography grids or ACOG for short and
as you can see in the picture on the
right these are essentially just a grid
of contacts that rests on the surface of
the cortex so there are two different
kinds of COG grids the larger one is the
standard clinical grid these are five
millimeter contacts with one centimeter
spaceman and then there's a smaller
denser version which we call mini ACOG
these have two millimeter contacts with
three millimeter spacing so the you know
the larger one at seven centimeters
across and they're been through one at
two centimeters across are still both
much much larger than before millimeter
across micro electrode array from the
previous slide and so when we stimulate
through these contacts we use larger
amplitudes of electrical stimulation and
we target a larger area of cortex so we
are working on a bi-directional
brain-machine interface and what that
means is that we are trying to record
neural signals of intent from kreidel
cortex or motor cortex and we interpret
those signals or decode them to control
an assistive device such as a robotic
hand and then that robotic hand might
have sensors embedded for example on the
fingertips by which it can acquire
sensor data when it interacts with
objects in the environment and our goal
then is to be able to encode the sensor
data and deliver it back to the brain by
electrically stimulating the cortex so
this is the area or the aspect of
bi-directional brain machine interfaces
that I'll be discussing today this this
problem of how to encode somatosensory
information and deliver it back to the
brain to do that I'll be first showing a
clip of an interview with the man named
Ian Waterman who at the age of 19 lost
all sensation but was not paralyzed and
so he is in the unique condition of
being able to move but not being able to
feel and in this video clip he discusses
how difficult it is to be simple
everyday
tasks which is holding a cup without
being able to feel play video since
sound whenever I'm working with my hands
or doing something of my hands I'm not
just looking into thinking about hands
I'm also attending to sound I mean I
can't get anything from my pocket
because I can't feel it terribly well
you know I can't I can't do something
because see often if someone passes me a
cup I would grab it awkwardly because I
don't have the feedback of something
coming from the fingertip saying you've
actually picked up the cup incorrectly
or taken it incorrectly so as you heard
in that video can you describe how
difficult it was to do the simple tasks
which is holding a cup without having
any sensation at all this really
captures what we're trying to do with
our clinical trials we're trying to be
able to restore the ability to sense as
well as to control to control these
assistive devices so next I'll play a
short video from our tetraplegic
research participant F key while he
experiences some biological stimulation
to the somatosensory cortex so you'll
notice in this video that ft describes
the sensations and feels in his own
words
and he'll also report the intensity of
the person up the felt on a scale of one
to ten and the duration of the per step
you felt short medium or long and as you
watch this video you'll see in the the
main portion of the screen you're
watching essentially what he saw on the
on the computer screen so there will be
cues to the different phases of the task
the inner trial interval or IGI the
stimulation with the purple dot and a
delay and finally the response and on
the right side of the video you'll see
representations of the two different
arrays implanted in somatosensory cortex
to indicate which electrode is being
stimulated during the stimulation phase
play video
oh yeah it doesn't it
medium grab mark
so you can see in that video that he was
able to identify very specific locations
on his body work he felt these persons
so this was one of the very first
questions we wanted to investigate where
did he feel these / steps versus where
which electrodes were stimulating on and
so here in this figure on in panel a on
the left you can see sort of the
receptive fields of where he felt these
per steps and they tended to be focused
primarily in the upper arm and green and
in the forearm in pink and then a little
bit in the hand and blue and then if you
look at the panel B which shows you
which electrodes correspond to which
area of the body you see that the medial
array tended to cluster responses to the
upper arm or as lateral array tended to
cluster response lists to ue4 arm which
generally follows the homunculus as you
might expect so then we also wanted to
look at the same question with the ACOG
epilepsy patients and so here you see
again that's this dense mini cog grid
and then there in the middle there's a
reconstructed image of a brain so on
that brain you can see highlighted in
blue as the motor cortex highlighted in
green is the somatosensory cortex and
then the the magenta dots are the mini
cog grid contacts and they're resting
right over the hand area of
somatosensory cortex and so with one
representative subject which went
through this experiment you can see that
this subject was able to identify more
experienced percepts in each of the
digits on the hand and then if you look
at which electrodes tended to generate
those per steps there is a clear
relationship between a specific
electrode and a specific digit and then
across all nine subjects that
participated in this experiment we found
similar observations where each of the
nine page
was able to identify receptive fields in
my hand and so clearly in both
modalities with microelectrode arrays
and with acog grids it's possible to
generate a percept in a very specific
location so it's also interesting to
look at what perceptive qualities people
feel and they're stimulated and it's a
matter of sensory cortex and so here a
list of the most common descriptive
terms the people used from both
modalities so for ACOG simulation
through the ACOG electrodes people
reported sensations such as a tap a
single tremble tickle buzz electricity
itch pulse shock and movement sometimes
whereas for the micro electrode arrays
there's the tap vibration squeeze
goosebumps press below pinch and then
upward movement right movement and
forward and so a couple things to note
here one is that with the micro
electrode array the terms that were used
that FG use to describe these per steps
tended to be more naturalistic than with
ACOG to me
excuse me Danny Hawk stimulation and
then secondly it's interesting to note
that he reported FGM reported several
instances of movement kinds of percepts
which are appropriated by quality now
when we stimulate we stimulate using a
biphasic charge balance pulse train and
an example of what that looks like is
shown here in black this is the square
wave form there are several aspects of
this wave form that we can control one
of you deliver stimulation for example
the amplitude a pulse width or key W for
short the frequency at which these
pulses appear and then the total
duration of the pulse train as well as
the electrode that we stimulate on this
becomes interesting when you start to
look at what changes and the waveforms
correspond to what kinds of changes when
the perceptual qualities that patients
experience so I mentioned earlier that
our subject FGM reported some movement
or proprioceptive light qualities and
some of the stimulation trials and here
I'm showing how those map onto the
different frequencies of stimulation of
the different amplitudes of stimulation
that we tested with them
as it turns out the proprioceptive
responses which are shown in blue as a
percentage of the total response and
ecstatic amplitude and frequency tended
to occur at higher amplitudes but across
all frequencies relative to the
cutaneous per steps which occur that
across all amplitudes and frequencies
and then if you look back on to what a
lecture generated these proprioceptive
versus cutaneous percepts there's not
really necessarily any clustering to one
array or the other and so this tended to
be a cross-reference with acog on the
other hand we found that higher
stimulation parameters in general at the
higher reported intensities in terms of
how the patient's described what they
felt so this is an example from to
patients and ACOG study subjects fixed
in subject 3 and we're looking
specifically at amplitude now so the
four different columns indicate
stimulation with amplitudes of 0.5
milliamps three milliamps five milliamps
and then finally 10 milliamps and as the
color gets darker that indicates a more
intense reporting and you can see for
subject 3 that the location of the
reported person up tended to change as
the amplitude increased so here are the
results for frequency for the same
subjects in the middle and then for
pulse width for the same subjects in the
middle and the overall takeaway here is
to see that as all three of these
parameters increased in value the
patients tended to report higher
intensities in whatever the perceptual
quality that they described so now a an
important aspect of sort of closing the
loop here is to identify whether it's
possible for people to use this
information to complete a behavioral
task so we did two of these with the
ACOG
Eclipse the patients and the first which
was a simple left-right discrimination
task patients simply held their hands
out over a piece of paper with two dots
on it they were not colored differently
in the experiment
except that one of them when the patient
held its hand over that particular dot
correspondent to receiving stimulation
and the other did not and the patient's
instruction was to identify which dot
correspondent to stimulation eight out
of the nine subjects participated in
this task and there was on average 100
percent accuracy and identifying the
correct dot on the paper the funding
were complicated tasks patients saw a
paper with a grid of nine dots not three
by three array and had to identify the
orientation of a line consisting of
three dots through that grid and so in
this image you can see one example
trajectory as one of the patient's
father's hand over the grid and started
searching for this line the
correspondence to stimulation and so
again out of eight of the nine subjects
that participated in this task there was
an average of ninety eight point three
percent accuracy so clearly these
patients were very much able to use this
information to can keep these relatively
straightforward behavioral tasks so over
the course of this presentation I have
described the way that we have
investigated generating somatosensory
Kerr sets for bi-directional p.m. eyes
with a extremely multidisciplinary team
so I worked very closely with scientists
engineers and clinicians and that
allowed us to work with a much broader
population of people as well as a
broader set of electro types we were
able to work with people with epilepsy
as well as with people at a chat feature
and we worked with both incog electrodes
that rested on top of the cortex as well
as intra cortical microelectrode arrays
where we're targeting a much smaller
area of cortex with smaller currents of
electricity and this I believe this
multidisciplinary approach allows us to
better understand how cortical
stimulation might be used to restore
sensation in the case of a person with
paralysis who has lost both the
abilities to move and if anymore so
stimulation through of somatosensory
cortex through ACOG mahogany reporter
rating clearly produces the
somatosensory per steps and it's clear
that we can target a specific somatic
talkie by choosing
correct electrode and that we can
generate qualitatively diverse types of
percepts and finally it's interesting to
note that there are different effects in
terms of changing the parameters for
these different devices on the different
scales of current that we generate
through them for the acog devices we
found that larger parameter values yield
more intensity but can be less specific
whereas for the micro electrode arrays
we found the proprioceptive per steps
were more likely than higher altitudes
and so in conclusion all of these things
help us to better understand how we
might be able to generate the
somatosensory percepts for
bi-directional pre-mission in our traces
which here hi my name is Tyson Afflalo
I'm a research scientist and executive
director of the Chen BMI Center at
Caltech I'm going to introduce you to a
clinical trial which record
simultaneously from posterior cortex and
motor cortex for neural prosthetic
applications in way of background the
majority of neural prosthetic clinical
trials have focused on using neural
signals recorded from the motor cortex
motor cortex is descending projections
are most directly responsible for
cortical control of the details of
movement during motor execution
however motor behavior is not solely
controlled by motor cortex but has
instead the product of an extended
network that integrates information from
our immediate visual environment
contextual factors and high level
behavior goals to determine which
behaviors to execute over the past six
years we have conducted fda-approved
clinical trials they use neural activity
recorded from arrays implanted outside
the motor cortex to provide assistive
technology and particularly we have been
planted at posterior parietal cortex
which all referred to as PPC the PVC
fits into this network as a critical
node for transforming visual information
into motor plans as well as monitoring
ongoing movements and demonstrating
neural control from BBC our clinical
trials have established that cortical
regions of the motor network outside
motor cortex enable closed-loop cortical
control of assistive devices our results
have shown that human PPC encodes many
useful signals that include the
trajectories of intended movements
similar to motor cortex but also many
other action related variables including
the goals of movement handshapes
cognitive motor strategy action
semantics and tended movements of
multiple body parts
even the decision of whether a visual
stimulus has been seen previously no
representations of these diverse action
variables are not randomly mixed at the
level of the population but instead are
systematically organized around movement
variables in an architecture we have
term partially mixed activity now that
clinical trials have demonstrated neural
prosthetic control signals from both PPC
and motor cortex an important question
is how BBC compares to motor cortex in
what ways are the signals from the two
regions similar in what ways might they
be complementary providing distinct
types of information that could be used
to enhance neural prosthetic function we
have recently initiated a clinic study
clinical study in which we implant PPC
and motor cortex in the same
participants to allow a direct
comparison here's participant JJ our
first subject with implants in both PPC
and motor cortex he sustained a spinal
cord injury in March of 2017 and a
go-cart accident we use functional node
imaging to help guide placement of Utah
electrode arrays the final implant
locations correspond to the hand knob of
motor cortex and the superior parietal
lobule of the posterior parietal cortex
the atlantean implantation surgery was
performed by not dr. Nader Pratt Ian at
UCLA we've had good recordings from both
brain regions that we typically get a
yield at single and multi unit activity
in the range of 100 to 150 units here is
a visualization of sorted neurons for
each are a participant JJ started no
positive control sessions in January of
2019 I'm about to show you an example of
closed-loop control from JJ's very first
clinical session this video is taken
after about four minutes of total neural
prosthetic control experience after some
parameters are updated here we are
combining activity from both brain
regions you can also hear JJ talk about
what he is doing to control the cursor
play video all right so what are you
thinking as you're moving the cursor
around
it almost feels natural if it's like
that I'm actually moving my wrist in
order to gotta cursor all the accesses
diagonal cross back to Center
it's not a cursor and sophis after
adjusting decoder parameters training
regimens and patient strategies in a
couple of weeks we were able to attain
control performance that is remarkably
similar to performance of motor intact
individuals again here we are combining
activity from growth regions play video
the prosthetic has worked great
allowing robust and versatile control
across a range of experimental tasks and
commercially available software but for
current purposes the primary question is
how the functional properties are the
two brain regions compare our clinical
trial has largely focused on using a
variety of experimental paradigms to
tease apart functional similarities and
differences between motor cortex and PPC
for this webinar I'll focus on
experiments that have probed the timing
of when intention related activity is
encoded in motor impact individuals one
key feature distinguishing high-level
motor intention regions like PPC for
motor cortex is the existence of
planning activity or neural coding of
what an individual wants to do before
they actually execute the action
planning activity is generally
demonstrated with delayed memory tasks
such as we see here in this task a
movement is instructed with a Q the Q is
extinguished during a delay period and
finally an instruction is given to
initiate movement in this case with a
luminance change of all targets this
task allows planning an execution to be
dissociated in time we know that motor
cortex activity is largely expressed
during motor execution on the right we
are looking at some represent
representative results for motor cortex
single cell recordings and non-human
primates and functional imaging and
humans shows an emphasis on execution
related activity in contrast high-level
regions like PPC but also areas like
premotor cortex amongst others include
the upcoming movement as soon as the
participant is given information that
informs the movement the functional
properties of motor cortex and PPC makes
sense given the location of these nodes
in the overall mode of production
Network PPC takes in visual information
and transforms this information into a
motor plan while m-1 converts plans into
coordinated movements however the
functional properties are identified in
motor intact individuals may not
generalize to patient populations that
utilize these neural prosthetic systems
this is because there are a number of
critical differences between the two
populations for example one key
difference is potential long term
plasticity that might result from spinal
cord injury
another key difference is is that the
neural prosthetic can fundamentally
alter how a cortical region contributes
to motor behavior let's take the case of
PPC PPC is a region that traditionally
plays a role in preparing movements
however in a neural prosthetic system
PPC is asked to directly produce
movements of a neural prosthetic
effector in this way we fundamentally
change its causal contribution of PPC to
the production of motor behavior this of
course will depend on how exactly to
activity is read out from these brain
regions through the course of the
experiments we are presenting in JJ we
have used both motor cortex and PPC as
motor output regions in other words our
algorithm directly translates
moment-to-moment fluctuations in neural
activity into force like signals that
update the instantaneous position of the
cursor thus due to the way we interpret
DP signals we truly are modifying its
console causal contribution to behavior
to assess the basic timing of signals in
motor cortex of PPC we had JJ perform a
delayed memory task using the neural
prosthetic system thus you would guide a
cursor to the to target under brain
control after the delay here I am
showing the results from the very first
session we ran a delayed memory paradigm
we are showing the percent of the
population that demonstrates significant
coding in movement direction as a
function of time and a sliding window
analysis the window is around 300
milliseconds this is an offline analysis
applied to the data that was acquired
during closed loop cortical control we
see that PPC encodes movement
immediately after the cue instructing
movement direction and this coding
continues through the time of movement
execution in contrast motor cortex is
largely restricted to the time of
movement execution thus despite the
spinal cord injury at the start of our
clinical trial responses are exactly as
predicted based on motor impact
individuals we then repeated the delayed
memory task as per addict intervals over
a ten-month period over this time the
subject attended sessions regularly
about twice a week and performed a wide
variety of girl prosthetic asks it
typically involved continuously
interaction with a prosthetic interface
these has simply did not involved in
force delay periods but instead
continuous control the question was with
long-term use of a neural prosthetic
changed the core functional properties
of the timing of intention related
signals so here we see the results of
the same tasks performed about 10 months
later the functional properties of both
regions are preserved this result
amongst other early results made clear
that functional distinctions between
motor cortex and TBC are preserved in
the clinical population and provide
distinct and complimentary
representations of motor variables the
fact that they preserve their properties
suggests that network connectivity
provides a strong constraint on the
types of activity patterns that these
brain areas can express this is not to
say that the functional properties are
completely immutable we have found that
a contextual manipulation can modify the
degree to which motor cortex expresses
activity during the planning period of
the task I'm going to present the
results of the delayed memory paradigm
with this contextual manipulation on the
Left I show what we call a brain coupled
version of the task the results for
which we were showing above in the
coupled version the neural prosthetic
system is always on that his neural
fluctuations are directly translated
into cursor motion throughout the entire
interval of the trial on the right I
show a schematic of what I call the
brain decoupled version of the task in
this version the neural prosthetic
system is essentially turned off except
for the NGO phase that is no
fluctuations are decoupled from cursor
movement during the Q and delay periods
what we find what we find is that when
brain activity is coupled to cursor
movements we see very little motor
cortex activity during the Q and delay
in contrast when the brain is decoupled
from cursor movement M 1 develops
activity these changes can be observed
through the course of a single session
we think this is likely the natural
consequence of certain optimality
principles at play but I cannot fully
elaborate the result due to time
constraints however I think it's
important sure that motor cortex
activity can express planning like
responses but only in certain limited
and unnatural contexts finally a high to
complimentary properties of these brain
regions for closed-loop continuous
control one motivation for implanting a
high-level region like PPC is that it
may enable faster decodes
from the delayed memory task we see that
PPC activity encodes the participants
intentions much earlier than motor
cortex
however the enforced electorate
exaggerated s' the differences in the
timing of PPC and motor cortex activity
do timing differences persevere when the
subject simply sees a stimulus and
reacts to it we are interested in 10th
in intent but not for instance visual
transients to ensure neural population
activity is encoding generalizable
intention signals we had the subject
performed neural prosthetic movements in
a task at interleaved pro trials in
which a change of color at the
peripheral target was used to instruct
movement and symbolic trials in which an
arrow at the center location instructed
the target this allows us to cue the
same intention with distinct visual cues
the subject perform this task in
closed-loop brain control an offline
analysis we used a sliding window cross
across conditioned classification
analysis that is we train the classifier
on the symbolically Q trials to predict
the provar trials and vice versa
this procedure ensures that the
classifier cannot cheat and use visual
information to boost accuracy for
simplicity here we are looking at the
average across condition accuracy and we
see that both areas generalized pretty
nicely but that PPC encodes the
intentions about 100 milliseconds faster
than motor cortex so from this
perspective PPC is better than motor
cortex conversely we find that m-1
better tracks the intentions of the
subject for long sustained movements to
demonstrate this point the subjects
performed a simple cursor control tasks
task but we slowed the cursor such that
movements took on average about two and
a half seconds to complete here we are
looking at cross validated
classification accuracy as a function of
time using a sliding window analysis we
see that emmalin sustains its
selectivity through the full duration of
the movement whereas PPC activity
attenuates as motor cortex better
represents the moment-to-moment
intention of the participant through the
full course of these slowdown movements
from this perspective motor cortex is
better than PPC I often get asked the
question how does the brain area that
you record from or does the brain area
record from really matter
human brain is the most powerful
statistical learning machine we know of
after all
but we find that the core functional
properties of brain regions are largely
preserved despite injury and novel
functional demands and further that
brain regions have distinctive and
complementary properties now there are a
lot of different ways that a neural
prosthetic system can be built and is
clear that brain areas should be
selected and decoding algorithms
tailored to harmonize with these
different implementations and I also
think you know that these findings truly
stress how neural prosthetics is a
multidisciplinary field it requires an
understanding and study of the brain to
understand what properties are available
for decoding combined with an ability to
decode these properties in real time
from populations of neurons and a means
of translating these decoded signals
into meaningful assistance these
required the disciplines of systems
neuroscience and cognitive neuroscience
statistics and machine learning as well
as engineering what hello I'm Charles Lu
I'm a neurosurgeon with an interest in
neural restoration my role is to manage
the clinical aspects of this complex
interdisciplinary project so in this
talk I'll briefly discuss some of the
clinical facets of this complex
interdisciplinary project involving long
term surgical implants in human
participants briefly touch on the
clinical needs for transformative
solutions to spinal cord injury we'll
talk about the complex clinical
resources that are necessary for
efficient interdisciplinary research
I'll make some comments about how we go
about identifying recruiting the ideal
research subject and we really consider
these subjects research partners of ours
there's not a lot of information about
how to do the surgeries properly so I'll
make some comments about these surgical
considerations for the optimal
implantation of these micro electrode
arrays and then I'll also touch on some
of the ongoing research subject needs
until the explantation is done and the
subjects exit from the project as well
as what their needs are beyond that so
it's important to consider the public
health dimensions
my own injury here are the latest
statistics from the National spinal cord
injury statistical center at a UAB I
circled some of the important points on
the slide you can see that there are
almost 20,000 new cases of spinal cord
injury per year and in the United States
they're approximately 300,000 people
living with spinal cord injuries so
we're talking about something that
certainly not an orphan disease again
this is a busy slide but more statistics
on spinal cord injury I want to focus
the audience's attention on the number
circled in red this is relates to the
costs both in monetary terms as well as
in human terms you can see that the
lifetime costs associated with a person
becomes tetraplegic at age 25 is
somewhere between four to five million
dollars depending on the level of injury
and you can also see with the number
circled in the bottom red circle that
these patients these people can live for
many years which leads to considerable
human suffering costs it really as a
result of this that the potential for
transformative solutions whether they're
found in regenerative medicine or in new
prosthetics research such as this
current project and this is very much in
the public consciousness and that as a
clinical person working with spinal cord
injury people I get asked about these
things all the time and you see that
it's actually made its way into the
magazine type publications I want to
spend a few minutes and just go over
what the resources are necessary if the
clinical resources are for accomplishing
this type of research complex studies
such as ours require acute care
resources and most of these can be
naturally found in centers where there
are active clinical DCI programs and
these are done for variety of
indications such as movement disorders
epilepsy pain disorders for the current
project these resources are found at USC
a Keck Medical Center
and in the slide you see two schematics
and one of course is of a deep brain
stimulator where penetrating electrodes
are placed deep into the brain and
attach to pulse generators for
indications such as movement disorder
and you see the the the image in the
bottom right corner of neuro paste which
is a bi-directional device that records
the seizure activities from implanted
electrodes and applies a simulation to
ablate those seizures beyond the
resources required for regulatory
oversight such as IR B's as well as
those required for the preoperative
resources for implantation there are
additional resources such as those
required for recruitment of study
participants and resources to manage
their ongoing needs we have embedded our
study at Rancho Los Amigos National
Rehabilitation Center which here is
shown in a beautiful image here that the
center was nearly rebuilt recently for
close to half a billion dollars Rancho
is one of only 14 National Institute of
disability independent living and
rehabilitation research funders bound
cord injury model systems and it's the
only one that's found in the West Coast
you see here really Rancho in the green
the red arrow pointing to the screen dot
here is the location of where our where
our rehabilitation center is here is a
view of the major public space in the
new outpatient building of Rancho this
is the space that sees the most traffic
from all types of all members of the
they array jewelers amigos community
when the building was created an artist
Deb ashram was commissioned to create
art for the space and she chose to put
Ranchos history on the wall
you can see that our project is
indelibly represented here you see this
red arrow pointing to this image and
Rachel really has a wonderful history
and the the current project is now a
very you know has been recorded as being
a significant part of it and of course
here is just a close-up on the image
that was pointed at in the last slide
the artists also created a wall with
video screens playing clips of ongoing
projects and our work continues to be
represented this is significant in that
the ranch of community can see the
research that's going on to solve
problems that's very personal to them
and in that way they can potentially be
interested in participating in these
projects for recruitment purposes we
have a very robust outreach outreach
program here in the slide you see dr.
Anderson moderating a discussion between
two study subjects with members of the
community of Rancho Los Amigos this
community of people's with disability
and you can see in the room there are
many people there or tetraplegic s--
this new patient expo will be held
annually and this makes the research
programs reachable and and then this way
we've embedded our research into the
community into the a veritable hub on
resources for patients with disability
gonna next touch on some of the issues
related to the surgical implantation
there is not much collective experience
with the implantation of Utah arrays in
humans and much of the science that
we're talking about here depends on the
quality of the implants we certainly
learned a lot in just the few implant
surgeries and humans that we've done so
I think it's worth making some comments
this is what the typical par for an
implantation looks like I'm here on the
left with the black cap the person in
the middle is that dr. Brian Lee
first on the right is uh Dan Kramer dr.
Kramer and both Brian and Darrin and for
me Brian and and Dan are alumni of the
Anderson lab there are quite a lot of
differences in the implant surgery in
humans that I think is worth commenting
on the first significant difference that
we've noticed is that the in humans the
leptomeninges can be quite thick and you
can find this thickening especially near
the veins this makes it potentially very
difficult to insert the arrays so we
have now modified our implantation
technique by removing the arachnoid
micro surgically and what you see in
this next video clip is just how thick
the arachnoid can be and what the
technique to remove it looks like go
ahead and play the video
you
so the other major issue that we
identified with the implantation of the
microarrays is that very often the
location of the ideal implant area can
be obstructed by relatively large
cortical arteries and veins but this can
be readily managed safely by a skillful
neurosurgeon with a good command of
microsurgical techniques and in this
next video clip you'll see us actually
moving a good-sized artery because it's
in the way of our implant go ahead and
play the video
you
so finally when the areas of implant are
exposed and the arrays are inserted into
the cortex using a pneumatic inserter
that's held by stereotactic frame here
you see what this looks like you notice
in the downward red arrow pointing at
the brain shift that makes the
management of the various gold wire
leads even more challenging in humans so
I wanted to just show a quick video clip
of what the pneumatic inserter
implantation process looks like in this
next video clip you'll see that we
brought the pneumatic inserter directly
over the micro electrode array and
you're gonna see that very quickly it's
it's going to essentially insert the
micro wires into the cortex and we're
gonna play the video twice because it
it's really easy to miss it
you
[Music]
so this slide shows that the surgical
plan that has been identified by the
research team that created by the
research team with the position of the
micro electrode arrays has been
perfectly executed you notice that the
s-1 arrays are implanted right next to
the large vein where the thickened
arachnoid was removed in the first video
clip and the PMD array is implanted next
to the loop of artery that was moved
that was shown in the second video clip
it turns out in this particular implant
all of the arrays are near vessels and
certainly that was not our choice but it
just so happened that these are the
places that we wanted to put the
electrode I want to just briefly touch
on the ongoing study participant needs
after the preoperative period we found
that progress of our research can be
limited by both participant physical and
social well-being and this is certainly
not trivial in this population these are
very fragile patients we were very
delighted to find that all of our
patients have enjoyed the project and we
continue to find ways for involvement
even beyond explantation and these
studies concluded for the participants
so to summarize the efficient neural
prosthetics research requires optimal
management of complex clinical resources
this can be achieved by embedding
advanced research into the ongoing
activities of a central hub for people
with disability and we've done that with
Rancho Los Amigos natural rehabilitation
center the neurosurgical aspects of
nurse prosthetics that implantation
requires further refinement and this
refinement can lead to
further efficiency in terms of advancing
the scientific goals finally I just want
to you know acknowledge the institutions
that are involved with the u.s.
denervation Center the clinical
resources described here in this talk
are drawn across a large number of
collaborators of the u.s. Dino
restoration Center thank you